a Wolverine and Deadpool friends or
enemies in Deadpool 3. set photos seem
to point to the latter or at least a
frenemy situation and for them that
means stabbing hey it's me don't scratch
Deadpool 3 will wrap up the Merc of the
mouse Trilogy that began in 2016 and
bring the Vigilante into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe he was previously
part of 20th century Fox's X-Men world
and it looks like the trilogy Kappa will
have fun at its former Studios expense
what makes this third installment even
more special in the eyes of fans is how
the Sean Levy directed film with fold
Wolverine into Deadpool's world but if
set photos are anything to go by the
Duo's long-awaited team-up will come
with some conflict verified set photos
have shown Deadpool battling Wolverine
actors Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
have long maintained a friendly rivalry
in the real world additionally Wade
Wilson The Man Behind Deadpool's blood
red mask often references Wolverine in
the movies especially their optimal line
first outing together X-Men Origins
Wolverine
[Music]
oh
I wouldn't do it
wouldn't do that now that sharing the
screen again with Wolverine getting a
comic accurate costume no less one of
the sent photos published by slash film
seems to show Deadpool's seriously
injuring Wolverine but given the fact
that both characters have healing
factors Logan probably won't bite the
dust in that capacity regardless
Deadpool's out for blood in these
pictures and considering there are also
photos of the wreckier to the 20th
Century Fox logo in the desert it
suggests Wade May kill Fox's Marvel
Universe which included Daredevil and
the Fantastic Four along with the X-Men
Deadpool's seemingly killing Wolverine
could reference the numerous times he
has died and come back in the comics
this is most apparent in The Death of
Wolverine Arc but he's also bit in the
dust in Days of Future Past and Enemy of
the State to name a couple of stories no
matter what the relationship between the
two ends of being in Deadpool 3 the
fight scene combinement that destroyed
20th Century Fox Monument suggested Paul
may be out to get everyone involved with
the fox Marvel movie it's also heavily
rumored that Mobius and Miss minister
the time variance Authority introduced
in Loki will factor into the movie what
if the TVA assigns Deadpool the mission
of pruning the 20th Century Fox branch
of the Marvel Universe Jennifer Garner's
lecturer who appeared in 2003's
Daredevil and her own Solo movie in 2005
is confirmed to appear after all there's
also a possibility Deadpool and
Wolverine could team up in this endeavor
anything's really possible with such a
massive playground and the backing of
Disney with a Multiverse in play it's
possible that several different variants
are both Deadpool and Wolverine could
pop up as well we've certainly seen that
before in other recent MCU films
who are you what
are you I'm just one of us the Deadpool
franchise has exceeded Against All Odds
proving that audiences can tolerate and
even celebrate an R-rated self-aware
superhero with a penchant for violence
was Deadpool 3 Levy and Reynolds who is
also a producer on the film had the
small task of not only wrapping up Wade
Wilson's story but also justifying the
inclusion of Wolverine who got a
ceremonious send-off in 2017's Logan
while speaking with SiriusXM Jackman
made it clear that the comic called
Deadpool 3 wouldn't interfere with the
grounded Logan saying that he wouldn't
screw the James Mangold directed film's
timeline all because of this device they
have in the Marvel world of moving
around timelines now we can go back only
time will tell how Wolverine will fall
into the Deadpool universe but it will
be interesting for fans to see why
exactly the duo are fighting is it
possible that other 20th Century Fox
Marvel heroes would join in on the fight
attempting to justify their existence in
a Cinematic Universe that has since been
Consolidated thanks to the MCU the
Marvel Cinematic Universe hasn't been
clear about his plans regarding the
X-Men franchise but it's highly probable
that they'll reboot the whole thing
casting new actors to play the numerous
characters having Deadpool kill off
previous iterations of these characters
would certainly be an inspired choice
but one that could prove to be
controversial with hardcore fans of the
previous films before Disney bought
Marvel Studios 20th Century Fox was
integral to Bringing these superheroes
to massive audiences one way or another
it's seeming like Deadpool 3 will be the
swan song and hopefully this chapter
gets laid to rest in style and with just
a little bit of a reverence it is a
Deadpool movie after all you can clean
up the timeline
foreign